i want to talk about some functions and
how they grow
we're going to do some comparisons okay
so over here we're going to have
a kind of function right i'm going to
name it much
we'll have the notation over here
and then we're going to test it out for
values of zero uh sorry values of x
right and we'll start with zero so i've
got these values
okay so
i want you to think about all the
classes of
functions that you know you're in you're
11 now you've learned about a whole
bunch of things it's sort of been
slowly building your catalog right
i particularly want to think about the
functions that grow because there's so
many different kinds of growth in the
world
that every time we understand something
different we say well this is behaving
differently there's a mathematical
function that should be underneath this
okay now i'm going to go in order
from slowest kind of growth up until
fast that's the order my table is going
to go in now before
i write down what my first function will
be i wonder what you think in your mind
just think to yourself what do you think
is the slowest
kind of function that you can
name right now i'm deliberately being a
bit vague about
different kinds of functions right
because like well you know
uh in the scheme that i'm talking about
x squared and x cubed
are actually kind of in the same class
of functions right
so i don't mean are there two different
ones because then i just have
x squared x cubed x to the four i said
that's a bit boring okay i
actually mean fundamentally different
kinds of functions
okay now would anyone like to suggest to
me what might be the slowest function
you can think of makita um
okay linear linear growth
is very very slow okay but it's not the
slowest it's the second slowest so we'll
get to it
in a second there's one that's slower
yeah
okay now circles they're kind of in
terms of growth it's a bit hard to
describe what's going on
because they're not really well for
starters circles are actually not
functions if i put in one value
i'll actually get two values back out
right because there's that symmetry to
it
so i wonder where circles would fit in
here but being that they aren't going
forever i'm gonna leave them aside from
it
doris can you just like
if it's just equal to something constant
can be like a constant okay so
i suppose if i said x equals three okay
yes i'm not growing all right so being
that that's like almost
trivial uh i suppose you could say
constant but that's not growth at all
so i'm gonna also leave that one off
there's still one that's slower
than linear growth it's in between a
linear
graph and a constant one think about it
this way okay
uh we understand linear graphs so we
understand as well right a linear graph
means
as you grow in number right
uh your actual result will grow at a
constant rate
constantly going up by one going up by
one going up by one
right now that means it's not slowing
down
if you were to think of it as a car it's
a car going at the same speed constantly
like a little highway
right 60 k's an hour not slowing down
not speeding up
if i'm thinking of one that's slower
than that what kinds of functions do we
know that behave like this
ah okay i'm gonna leave out root
functions they're a bit funny
but logs logs are something you looked
at
last year and how do logs work why would
as a rhythmic growth
right means that the bigger your number
gets the slower it grows
does that make sense and you can see it
in the graph the graph of a log graph
looks like this
it never actually goes level it never
stops increasing
but it slows down dramatically okay so
you've got that kind of great thing
the square root of x or the cube root of
x or whatever kind of looks the same
but for reasons that it will become
clear then i'm going to leave that out
so look at the growth let's just think
of an example okay let's go
log base 2 okay of course i could have a
peak base 3 base 4 base 5 but they're
all doing much the same thing
on a different scale right so if i put
x equals 0 into that just for example
what do i get
it's a log graph right there's no
solution because at x equals zero
at x equals zero i have an asymptote
don't know so i'm just going to put n a
there
not applicable when i get to one
now i have a value because log base 2 of
1
what power do i raise 2 2 to get 1 and
the answer is 0
right ok log base 2 of 2
is 1 right okay and now it's like oh ok
i i don't know what log base two of
three is
if you have your calculator there and
you remember your change of base
laws how is it that i actually work out
the numerical value of log
base two of three does anyone remember
log base two of three okay we have to
use a fraction here to do change of base
right is anyone remember okay so you
pick
you pick any other base you like fine so
for example
let's go base e right so you put the top
one on the top
and you put the bottom one on the bottom
simple okay so what do i get what's our
numerical value can i get one decimal
place that's all i want
1.6 okay now you can see what's
happening here right we're already sort
of mentally comparing
to linear growth even though i haven't
written that in yet from here to here
things looking good i increased by one
and i increased by one
but i'm slowing down aren't i can you
give me the next one without typing it
in
it's going to be 2 isn't it log base 2
of 4 2
squared gives me 4. so i've got 2. again
i'm slowing down
okay you'll need your calculator for
this one someone give me above
two point three log base two of six
two point six two point six all the way
to seven
two point eight two point eight all
right so even just to one decimal place
which is not super accurate
you can see it's slowing down all right
so next row pretty simple linear growth
the classic form of linear growth is
just x
y equals x right and for x
your values are just the same right so
you can see it just marches along
and it just keeps on going okay
now then comes the question what comes
in next not some linear growth well
clearly it's going to be something that
keeps growing but it grows not at a
slower rate
or a constant rate but a faster and
faster rate
right so now before i get to
exponentials there's similar kinds of
graphs that we've met
much earlier than exponentials that fit
in next and i even alluded to them this
morning
they are a class of functions called
polynomials
and we call this polynomial growth
or if you're a um a computer programmer
and you're trying to get your computer
to solve problems for you
sometimes the size of your problem well
almost always the size of your problem
increases the time
required to solve that problem and often
the amount of time is called polynomial
time right so example x squared
so we know the values here we can pop
the square numbers in there 0 1
4 9 16 25
36 49 okay
so these cl these clearly are out
stripping everything before
after polynomial growth then comes in
exponential
all right well let's have a look at
exponential group just for the kicks
because i chose
for my log graph i chose base two so why
don't we keep
base two here okay so now all i'm doing
here
is i'm swapping the power and the base
so to the power of naught
one wow out of the gate i'm already
faster that's nice
to the power of um so true to the club
naught is one two the power of one
is two so now i'm because of the power
that i've chosen i'm doubling every time
aren't i
so here right this is kind of
interesting
there's an intersection there and it
looks like
i'm slower right slower
equal oh no i am going to leave this guy
in the dust
forget it okay you can see exponential
growth it just completely outstrips
a um a polynomial now just as a point of
interest
if i would you might say well that's
just because you chose 2. x squared's
not that fast i could do x cubed up to
the 4
to the 5. fair enough eventually
you'll have like you know there's going
to be some amount of time where
the polynomial sure enough will be
higher than the exponential
but not for long the exponential will
always catch it no matter how low the
base is
yeah hmm a hyperbola is not really kind
of growth either
it's it's reducing right unless of
course you think about
you can think about other kinds of
hyperbola like that yeah but they're not
relation they're not functions they're
relations
okay so that's why i'm leaving them out
of this discussion
also just really quickly if you if you
think about it
i'm not going to go into depth but just
because you mentioned it
um it's interesting the the hyperbola
that we're all familiar with is one on x
right that's the hyperbola we've met
before but one or next is not growing
it's shrinking right it's going it's
going one and then a half and then the
third and then a quarter and then a
fifth is getting smaller
now not all hyperbola do that for
instance if i take that hyperbola one
over x
and i rotate it so i'll look like this
now just for a second for the sake of
argument let's just forget about that
bottom part
which is not problematic right let's
just think about the top part
just look at it for a second look
carefully don't say anything
just look at it
if you could classify this in terms of a
kind of growth
where would it fit
what is it closest to it looks to me
like it's closest
to linear in fact that's what it's
approaching
forever so actually you're going to be
all the way up here
it's a bit disappointing isn't it okay
so anyway
i have one more kind of growth to show
you and it's the focus of
today what's faster than polynomial
growth
and exponential growth
factorials now i always wondered
i always wondered factorials you've got
the factorial button right in the top
right hand corner of your calculator
the notation for something like
x factorial is an exclamation mark
why is it an exclamation mark
well let's give this a go now i've
started off at zero
right you can have a think about it you
say hold on
what is a factorial the most basic
definition that most people hear is
oh you know something like say three
factorials
three factorial is you start at that
number and then you go down and multiply
then you go down and multiply and then
you stop
right so then what would that be
because you're like zero now the
interesting thing is
if you go to your calculator you push in
zero factorial
and it very dutifully tells you that the
answer
is one okay now just on its own
that there's no profanity to that that's
not a profound result the calculator is
telling you that
because a human has told the calculator
to tell you that
okay a more profound question is
why would any human why would a
mathematician decide
the best meaning for zero factorial
is one because that doesn't fit with
this definition
what definition are they thinking of i'm
just going to leave that question
hanging for a little while
all right the rest of these we can do
one factorial
one looks a bit boring at the moment not
even growing
okay that's all right hold on two
factorial is two times one which is
two three factorial is three by two by
one which
is six all i'm doing really is i'm
taking this previous number
and i'm multiplying by the new number
that i just got right
gee it really didn't take me long did it
right i've already left them in this
button
just for the sake of it you know just
for the walls let's see
what happens uh by six
by seven five thousand forty wow
can you see now why the mathematician
who first started working on this
said what notation should i use to
describe
this guy and he decided i think i'll go
for the exclamation mark
okay so this this growth is crazy
okay so this shows you the context this
shows you why it's an exclamation mark
now let's do a bit of work with it